hey what's up guys mkbhd here back with
another hd video review and today we're
going to be taking a look at the monster
mobile jams headphones now i want to
start off this review by saying one
thing and it's actually written on the
case that comes with it life is too
short to listen to bad headphones and to
be honest if you're going to go out and
spend over a hundred dollars over a
hundred and fifty dollars on an mp3
player say your zoom hd your ipod
something like that why on earth would
you stick with the standard earbuds that
come with it the 20 to 30 dollar ones
that come with the mp3 player not
bashing apple not bashing microsoft for
throwing in terrible headphones but i
just want to say that really consider
spending more money on your headphones
than just the terrible ones that come
with it so without any further ado these
are the monster jams and i'll be honest
i really like the case despite all the
writing it has on it says monster has a
little tag here jam on
live is too short for a bad headphones
and all the gems and it's a really nice
felt sort of design it's very durable at
the top it's magnetic and inside we have
the mobile jams themselves
now taking them out like this brings me
to point number one
this is one of the few monster
headphones that does not have an
anti-tangling cable however it does
untangle fairly easily so as you can see
here
this is the wire and this is uh the buds
themselves so we'll start on this end
and work our way to the buds we have a
three and a half millimeter uh
headphone jack obviously audio jack very
standard
it's also gold plated but it is not the
right angle cable i think the one thing
i would suggest is i guess about these
headphones is to for them to include
a right angle cable instead of this
regular cable i really like the right
angle campbell with the other monster
headphones anyway moving our way up here
i'll include the length of the cord in
the description but then about halfway
up or a little more than halfway up we
get this section here
this is uh you'll probably see this in a
lot of headphones but this is where a
lot of the chrominess starts
you'll have this piece to slide up and
down and adjust how close they are uh
and how close uh these two wires are
together two ears but this is where it
splits and this also does say monster on
it if you can tell there you go it says
monster then on the other end we have
the focus of this review video and i'll
have to go ahead and untangle these
these are the mobile jams buds
themselves there are a lot of
interesting things about these that
first caught my attention but i really
got used to pretty quickly number one is
that they are pretty shiny um they are
very durable if you haven't seen the
video review or the video testing these
they ran over these with a tractor for
crying out loud so these are very
durable second of all they are kind of
heavy as a matter of fact
and they're made of solid metal uh and
you'll pay the price and the thing that
i notice is when i was walking with
these they did tend to move around my
ears and uh break the seal and come
loose
but
uh i'll tell you what sitting down these
are some of the nicest in your
headphones i've used in a very long time
now taking this off here you can see it
does have a pretty large driver
and that's definitely going to reproduce
base frequencies nicely but i noticed as
the mids and highs were really really
good i was impressed by the mids and
very very impressed by the highs of the
mobile gems so the right is the right
hand side red is right and blue is left
so that's basically it for the mobile
jams you're going to get like i said
pretty good quality for in your
headphones when you're just sitting down
and listening to music i wouldn't really
suggest these for walking around and
using in-ear headphones but i i
typically haven't had a great experience
with in-ears but these have been really
impressive i might be open to try
a different pair of in your headphones
in the near future we'll see how that
works out but these are a a pretty
impressive pair of in-ear headphones
pretty good sound quality very good
build quality up here
down here on the audio uh the cable end
into your mp3 player could probably use
a little bit of work as it's not quite
as
heavy-duty as these guys but they're
very very strong earbuds
that's about all i have to say about the
mobile jams by monster i'd like to thank
them of course for sending these for
review
and that's about as much as you can say
about headphones so until next time this
has been mkbhd signing out peace